est-ce que vous y étiez le fameux jour
où a eu lieu l'accident
c'était une nuit de quel sexe
de la consommation de drogues de
l'alcool
dans quel climat
d'accord
un petit moment
et on apprend quelque chose de fou avant
le drame il avait déjà pris la voiture
complètement défoncée apparemment pierre
Palma de conduire
le même vendredi
personne ne lui disait
c'est dangereux tu devrais pas conduire
ce genre de choses
et enfin il y a eu une troisième vidéo
concernant les soupçons de vidéo
pédopornographiques le proche défend
Pierre Palmade pour cette personne
pierre Palma aurait montré une vidéo
pour dire à quel point il en était
choqué en fait c'est ce qui c'est la
version qui donne rien
[Musique]
face à l'axe dans ce genre de d'histoire
en fait vous voulez dire qu'il n'est pas
pédophile
mais est-ce qu'il regarde des vidéos
pédo pornographiques
de défonce parce qu'il vous arrivez de
regarder ensemble non des vidéos
[Musique]
j'avais essayé de demander à quelqu'un
mais montre-moi les vidéos avec la
petite fille et le vieux monsieur que tu
m'as montré on voulait en quelque sorte
piégé la personne qui nous montrait des
vidéos alors Claude Fournier nous a
rejoint c'est le producteur historique
de Pierre Palmade on va parler avec lui
dans un instant juste Michel Marie faut
voter spectateur c'est avec l'affaire
rebondit tous les jours quels sont donc
est-ce qu'on sait un petit peu qui est
cette personne là qui parlait là
c'est sans doute un prénom d'emprunt est
à personnage assez central dans cette
histoire
elle était présente
assez liant bien elle était elle venait
de partir au moment de l'accident elle a
ce qu'il y a plein de gens qui ont dit
je vous dis les spectateurs je me fais
la vocabulaire ils ont pris quelqu'un
dans le parc ils ont mis un bonnet je
vous dis la vérité
à la soirée
ça peut être n'importe où on sait pas si
c'est un homme ou une fille on sait pas
c'est une Barka c'est un mec il était
tranquillement en train de jouer au foot
tu me mets ce bonhomme
ça va durer 2 minutes t'inquiète pas tu
fais ce qu'on dit
je ne pense pas d'accord le personnage
existe il a été en garde à vue il a été
entendu par la brigade des mineurs de
protection des mineurs et je vous le
disais c'est un personnage central parce
que il est il a participé à la fois à
ces quelques jours qui ont précédé
l'accident ou camille a participé aux
chêne sexe
a vécu ces moments est parti un petit
peu avant l'accident parce que
insupportable cette image enlevé là
franchement
divers on dirait un mec on dirait un
persiste à qui j'ai compris
alors dites-nous oui non mais c'est vrai
donc le Camille existe dans la vraie vie
je pense que c'est Camille d'ailleurs
qui est qui est derrière vous donc de
neige et Camille
était a eu entretenu une relation avec
avec Pierre Palmade et elle il
finit par s'y perdre Mathieu il est pas
moi et c'est toi pardon
parce que vraiment tu es vraiment
avec le bonnet merci et donc oui
l'histoire est déjà très compliquée
si vous me coupez à chaque fois je vais
avoir du mal
il y a une info importante qui est dans
l'interview et surtout qui a été dans
l'audition de Camille c'est cette
première entre guillemets escapade en
voiture avant dans l'après-midi parce
que ça veut dire que les enquêteurs qui
ont auditionné Camille ont su que Pierre
Palmade dans un état déjà selon Camille
défoncer prenez une voiture et ça
explique aussi pourquoi ils ont souligné
dans le dernier arrêt le risque de
réitération c'est-à-dire que dans des
étapes pas possible il est capable de
prendre deux fois sa voiture donc il
pourrait la reprendre ça explique parce
qu'on se demandait aussi non mais on
demande
le fait qu'il soit écroué participe
aussi de cette des déclarations de ce
personnage Camille effectivement est au
centre des affaires
ce qui est important c'est que Camille
connaît Pierre Palmade depuis au moins
trois ans
je ne suis pas sûr d'y arriver
non mais
bah alors pour savoir
et donc
toute la journée il y a des mecs qui
m'ont dit Cyril tu ne sais pas ce qu'ils
ont fait BFM aujourd'hui ils ont mis une
personne de dos on sait pas si un homme
ou une femme avec un Bonnie et en fait
et on qui qui témoigne c'est des génies
voilà donc voilà donc c'est vrai que
voilà donc je pensais à ça et c'est
extrait m'a fait énormément rire alors
Michel je pense que le personnage est
vrai bref c'est très bien peu importe
donc Camille est un personnage central
Camille comme vient de dire Gilles
Verdez a participé à raconter un certain
nombre de choses sur la soirée et sur
les heures qui ont précédé l'accident
rien qu'on ne sache déjà d'ailleurs
beaucoup de drogues beaucoup de sexe en
revanche Camille est également
présente sur les fameuses vidéos
pédoporno en tout cas
son explique Lady en fait voilà
en tout cas sur le téléphone de Pierre
Palmade il semble qu'il y avait ce
fameux téléphone qui a été vendu via
Camille ce téléphone s'est retrouvé à
Bordeaux chez un individu qui a essayé
un moment donné de monnayer cette vidéo
quand il a découvert que Pierre Palmade
avait des problèmes avec le avec cette
accident
quand je pèse mes mots
et ces photos il y a une dénonciation
bref la police a fini par récupérer le
téléphone
ce fameux téléphone qui contenait des
des films des des scènes et on voit sur
ce sur ces scènes Camille et un jeune un
jeune asiatique et on voit également
Camille c'est Saturne fille
on le voit de profil
c'est une jeune fille quoi voilà donc
jeune fille mais c'est un garçon
exactement
et
Camille et un jeune asiatique figure sur
la vidéo sur une des vidéos et on entend
la voix de Pierre Palmade et on le voit
et alors la scène c'est qu'ils sont tous
en train de regarder un film pédoporno
ça c'est avéré voilà
donc Camille
une fois de plus est au centre des
choses parce que c'est elle qui a vendu
le téléphone de Pierre Palmade ils ont
pas nettoyé ce téléphone il y avait
resté ses prises de vue elles sont assez
nombreuses a priori
alors là où il y a un vrai problème si
vous voulez c'est que Pierre Palmade qui
est quand même le principal intéressé
n'a toujours pas été entendu dans ce
dossier il a été entendu sur l'accident
par par les enquêteurs et puis par le
jus d'instruction et en revanche sur
tout le volet pélo-porno
il a pour des raisons de santé pour
l'instant pas encore été entendu donc
c'est c'est toujours compliqué de
raconter des alors elle était elle était
elle était avec Pierre Palma dans il
était avec Pierre Palmade lors de ces
fameuses nuit blanche avant le drame oui
voilà donc elle a dit comment c'était
déroulée la soirée
elle confirme d'énormes prises de drogue
ce qu'on disait hier des voitures une
première fois oui il avait pris sa
voiture en fin de matinée pour aller à
la pharmacie et d'ailleurs Camille était
dans la voiture à ce moment-là elle doit
pas dire il doit pas dire conduit pas
dans cet état
d'accord et il y en a pas il y en avait
pas un pour relever l'autre comment dire
donc ils sont partis tous totalement
défoncé ils sont allés à la pharmacie
ils sont revenus et a priori il semble
qu'il y a eu un incident entre Camille
et Pierre Palmade il devenait agressif
désagréable et Camille probablement sous
l'effet de la drogue et Camille a
préféré partir d'accord juste sa
contredit ce qu'il a dit aux enquêteurs
ou pas du tout
sur le sur le volet de l'accident oui ça
contredit parce qu'il lui dit qu'il a
pris qui prenait très rarement sa
voiture quand il était dans cet état là
on s'aperçoit qu'il a pris quand même
deux fois dans la journée bon est-ce que
c'est une coïncidence j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas oui ça ça contredit sur
ce point en tout cas